>> LEE: Hi, my name is Bob Lee. I'm the core
library lead for Android, and I'm here to
show off a couple of my favorite Android features.
I spend most of my time in the web browser.
I can keep up with my friends on Twitter,
or can switch windows using Android’s window
feature, and keep up with the latest news
on Google Reader. Here we go. We’re following
politics because we have the upcoming election.
I can scroll through and look at the items
until I find the item I'm interested in. Here’s
one by Esther Dyson, for example. I can click
on the item, and it automatically expands,
use an Ajax. I can scroll through the item
and I read it here, and with the size of the
screen and what not, it’s very easy to read
full stories. I can scroll down and I can—if
I want to look at the original webpage, all
I have to do is click the “See Original
Length,” and Android’s browser opens up
that webpage in a different window. When I'm
not coding on Android, I'm an aspiring photographer,
so I love the fact that you can copy—I can
copy my photos onto the ST card and pull them
up in the picture app, so… And then show
them off to my friends. Here’s a picture
of my favorite subject. And I just click the
error buttons, and I can navigate through
the pictures. Or I can click “Menu”, and
then tap “Slide Show.” It will go through
them automatically.